so maybe yeah maybe we should just start
out explaining like what is Lego Lego is
a huge project aimed at being able to
take the bending of space that we that
we think is happening all the time and
turn it into some kind of signal that we
can use and measure and yeah it's a
transducer it's like having a voltage
meter or a microphone but it's a like a
microphone for space can you do the
beginners explanation of what what it
actually is what the device actually is
yeah so we think we now know based upon
the Einstein's relativity theory from a
hundred years ago that there isn't a
real force of gravity like there is a
force between magnets or between charges
or things like that but instead the way
that gravity works is that a curved
space and so it's a lot like imagining
what happens when you're jumping up and
down on your bed and somebody else is
jumping on or that I guess because if
this happens to you all the time then
this is something you're familiar with
but who whoever's heaviest makes a big
impression in the bed and then whoever
is little or has to account what a kind
of an analogy of this whoever's littler
has to account for the depression in the
middle of the bed and adjust their
jumping accordingly any and you tend to
slide into the the biggest dimple in the
bed so those those who do trampolines
are jumping up and down on their bed
understand how yeah well trained and
understand how gravity works so did
detect this on the earth is incredibly
hard and people have long ago measured
the curvature of a space due to the
earth and due to the moon and other
planets and that sort of thing and so we
well understood that in fact space is
curved but we had no evidence to support
the idea that the curvature of space
could travel through space as waves the
the detection of gravitational waves you
know for decades had been debated in the
scientific community people thought it
was just imaginary that it was waves of
thought
people called it because they thought it
was just you know waves of mathematics
it was just some equation he wrote down
what didn't make any sense was just kind
of a nonsense thing and some decades ago
people realize it was real and then some
crazy people said hey let's try to
measure this even though it was millions
of times not pop I mean like factors of
millions not possible
but luckily through a this is just
something I'm not capable of but through
a combination of optimism and courage
and not knowing the right answers to
several equations they were able to
start up the field and start to look for
these things if they think they had
known how tough it would be or that it
was going to take 55 years to have
success probably no one would have
started and so now here in the modern
times is the way we do it is we use the
tool of laser interferometry which is
for those of you who are you know for
ometer aficionados it is a Michelson
type interferometer with a lot of extra
stuff added onto it though for those who
are not the concept is simple it just
has to do with interference so you take
mm a laser like a laser pointer but much
more expensive and therefore much more
stable is it a billion dollars now into
the project yeah roughly yeah the laser
itself is cheaper you can do probably
you could do the whole thing with
$100,000 laser okay
that's about the laser cost you split it
in two and you send it in two separate
directions and then when the waves come
back they interfere with each other and
you look at differences in that
interference to tell you the difference
in how long it took for one beam to go
one way and the other beam to go the
other way mm-hmm and so this the way I
said it was really careful there because
there's a lot of confusion about the
idea of there these are waves and space
is bending and everything's shrinking
and how come the lights not shrinking
and so on
we don't really know there's there's no
real difference between the ideas of
space and time warping it could be space
warping or time warping but the only
thing that we really know is what we
measure and that's the mantra over the
of the true empirical person I guess we
send out the light and the light comes
back in interference and the pattern
changes and that tells us something
about effectively the delay that the
light saw and it could be that the
space-time curved said that the light
took longer to get there but you could
also imagine that there was a change in
that in the time in one path as opposed
to the other instead of the space but
it's a mixture of space and time so it
sort of depends on your your viewpoint
but this warping of space-time is what's
measured and we turn it into a real
signal by putting the interference of
the of the two beams onto a usual photo
detector that's like like a solar cell
that you would use and so it turns light
into electricity and that's the whole
thing and then you measure it in by
looking at waves that the whole
measurement is right there and the
electrical signal out of the photocell
okay
and so then how do you go about
converting it to I you know I've seen a
bunch of these like sound sounds of
things you've measured how do you go
about that process yeah it's the same as
like an electrical instrument if you
have an electric guitar when you play
whatever you're playing on there it
generates an electrical current and the
pickup coils of the guitar and that
signal comes out through a little cable
and goes into an amplifier mm-hm and
then that's directly makes sound and the
same for us okay so the photo detector
detects a signal which turns into
electricity and then we take that
electricity and we drive a speaker and
then it makes sound okay so there's no I
I can understand what you're asking that
seems like a little weird how is it that
the wave from outer space
directly get turned into a signal in the
speaker it happens to be and then I
think this is a whole nother topic to
discuss it happens to be that the waves
is that we are detecting in the waves
which are easiest to detect are exactly
in the human audio band mm-hmm so the
waves that you and I can hear with our
ears that's the that's the whole
frequency range for gravitational waves
that we can detect they gravitational
waves happen at all frequencies but
they're really loud right in this band
and so our detectors are aimed for this
band because we expected the audio band
would be a good place but our technology
also happens to be only capable of
detecting things in this band heard a
lot of technical reasons which I can I
can tell you about that happens to be
the case and so it is it is a little
weird but the signals directly make
sound hmm so what I wanted to to talk
about then I saw in one of your talks I
guess it was from last year you're
talking about creating new kinds of
mirrors to focus rather the mirrors that
you had created focused that like the
vibrations to certain parts of mirrors
but you were working on creating new
mirrors to detect other things we're
dealing with yeah exactly yeah the when
I first heard about it it was you know I
was I was gonna say when I first heard
about it I thought maybe it was
unbelievable but I have to say I don't
think ever when I first heard about this
project I don't think I understood
enough to even understand that it was
impossible so I never went through this
this belief belief period I just kind of
slowly merged into it but a lot of
people with good reason say it's
impossible to make these measurements
and the reason is if you imagine zooming
into where the black holes are in outer
space
they're like a billion light years ago a
few billion light years ago and the
universe is only thirteen billion light
years thirteen billion years old so it's
a good fraction of the size of the known
universe
away and if you get close to these black
holes the amount as they're merging and
eating each other the amount that the
space is warping is enough so that like
this water glass it would be shattered
but it would be stretched if it was
stretchable too you know like this would
be a huge stretching but the wave as it
propagates to us like waves do they get
attenuated to imagine this stretching
has a lot of energy in it but as it
spreads out the amount of energy has to
be conserved as it as it propagates and
so the amplitude of the wave as it comes
to us gets reduced like one divided by
the distance and so the energy the or
the energy in the wave goes like one
divided by the distance squared like any
other kind of radiation we measure the
amplitude instead of the power we
measure directly the stretch rather than
the heat or something like that so we're
able to look a lot deeper into the
universe than you would naively expect
because our our signal only decays like
one over the distance instead of the
distance squared okay so so the wave
comes to us and by the time it gets to
us because it's billions of light years
the squeezing and stretching is much
less than 500 percent it's more like a
part in 10 to the 21 or 22 so that means
if you have the whole earth for example
is about 10,000 kilometers in size and
so that the whole earth will be only
stretching by about one hundredth of a
micron I don't even know how to imagine
that what's at micron micron is like the
wavelength of light all right or my hair
is the diameter of my little hair I have
here is is about a hundred microns so
it's ten thousand times smaller than the
width of this hair it's how much the
entire earth would stretch yeah when it
was hit with the gravitational wave that
you
initially measured yeah okay which is a
large one which is a very large one
we've not seen anything of that size
since then since that first one and so
that's such a tiny distance our
detectors are big they're four
kilometers so they're not ten thousand
unfortunately if I was in charge I would
drill through the center of the earth
and there would be mirrors I would have
put a big L in the center of the earth
and then there would be mirrors on both
ends and then the ideal we would that
would be ideal and that's what we would
use but I'm not yet in charge of
everything but then okay so to divert a
little bit can you explain how the the
fabry-perot interferometer works like
because it's not it's four kilometers
but it's also kind of like bounce back
and forth at the same time right yeah so
effectively it's actually longer yeah
the laser travels a longer distance yeah
that's right
so the it's it like it's if the
fabry-perot cavity means rather than
just send the laser beam down we send it
into a thing which has two mirrors into
it and just like I don't know if
everybody does this but when I was a kid
I wondered
here's his bathroom mirror and what if
you know I can see my reflection and
then if I go into the funhouse
they're like during Halloween I can see
multiple reflections and what if you put
two mirrors together and you set a
flashlight then you took it out would it
bounced around infinity times and
explode the mirrors and you know I've
always tried you know I wondered about
it and it turns out no sadly you cannot
destroy the universe but they sent two
mirrors together one kid didn't figure
it out yeah yeah and it and the reason
is because the at each mirror surface a
little less than 100 percent of the
light gets reflected back some of it
gets turned into heat or things like
that and so the fabry-perot optical
resonator is just two mirrors facing
each other and one of them has a finite
transmission so it's set up so that
let's say 1% of the light comes out and
99% goes in mm-hmm
or you know 99% gets reflected and 1%
goes through that's the hundred percent
and so when you set it up at first you
have these two mirrors and you put in
the beam from this side let's say and
only a little bit gets in and so that
little bit gets in and starts bouncing
around but by the time it comes back
you're already putting in more laser
light you're constantly putting in more
laser light and that builds up
constructively with the waves
electromagnetic waves you're sending in
and slowly the power builds up in the
system just through this little leakage
and it builds up until the point where
the amount coming out is about the same
as the amount going in mm-hmm and at
that point you have like let's say a few
hundred times more laser power in this
system than if you had just sent in a
single beam and that's that's not so
challenging it's easily doable and it
gives you basically a factor of 200
extra sensitivity than you would get so
the extra power of the laser generates
more sensitivity yeah it's just just
like you said it though it's it's
effectively like the laser bounces a
bunch of time okay and so you can
imagine here's this space-time which is
curved so now the laser has to travel
through this curved path and so it's a
little bit longer of a distance and when
it goes down and comes back it picks up
a little bit of extra a phase shift it's
just a delay and now that's through one
round-trip and if you do 200 round trips
you get 200 times the phase shift and so
that's what we do but does that net out
200 times the noise as well yeah it does
exactly so the more the more times you
go around and the more you you pick up
the signal from the mirror motion yeah
and so the signal-to-noise you know
trying to get below the fluctuations of
the mirror don't actually get better by
building it more power in the system and
in fact if it can even go the wrong way
at some love at some point the quantum
mechanical fluctuations and the the
number of photons that are in your
system becomes so large that the mirrors
are shaking and so the more power
or you have it just gets worse and so
there's a limit to how much power you
want to put in there before you get into
trouble okay but so you might reasonably
ask why do you do it then if it doesn't
help it helps it helps just in building
up the signal and if you're limited by
the fluctuations of the mirror motion
due to the environment or something like
that then more power is not any good mmm
but most of the time in most cases when
people are doing precise measurements
with lasers that are limited not by the
mirror motion by but by the noise due to
the fact that the they have a finite
number of laser photons so if you just
take a laser and put it on to a
photocell and you listen to it with
yours your speakers which you can do it
sounds kind of like a hiss and that hiss
is because quantum mechanically the
energy of the light is sort of is in the
discrete packets which we call photons
and so if you have a 1 watt laser or
something like that you have some many
billions and billions of photons but you
you end up with a hiss level of noise
due to the basically the quantum nature
of the light that you can't get beyond
and increasing laser power builds up
your signal so if you double the laser
power you double your signal but your
noise due to these random photon
fluctuations only goes up like the
square root of that power okay so you
win a little bit for that particular
noise and why not just have a
super-powerful laser we do we do have
super powerful lasers okay but you need
it to be even stronger yeah yeah it is
tough to build a super powerful laser
trying to think of how to put this in
context so the people who have worked
work with these lasers will will
understand why we do it this way if you
have these days like if you have $50,000
in your pocket you can go on to the
internet and buy
self scientific research grade laser
that's a couple of watts and will work
fine for you and we end up with a 200
watt laser and there's no such you can't
buy anything like that these days you
can buy lasers that have that much power
but their frequency is not very stable
and our laser is used as the meter stick
for doing the measurement it's like each
wave the laser is one tick on a meter
stick and if you have an unstable laser
that means these little waves instead of
being very precise or jiggling all over
the place mm-hmm and so your meter stick
it would be like having a meter stick
where the the tick marks are kind of
dancing around right you can't use it to
measure anything right and it's so
precise because like just so I don't
mistake it the the first the two black
hole measurement how much should it move
about 10 to the minus 18 meters which
means one billionth of a about the size
of a atom small so yeah you can't do
that you can't do that so you have to
there's no laser in the world which is
good enough to measure this and so we
take the best laser in the world that we
can find and then we stabilize it and
make it about ten million times more
stable than what you can buy and then
it's it's kind of just barely good
enough and we're gonna have to do better
if we want to do better yeah so maybe
that makes sense like what changed
between LIGO and advanced LIGO was it a
shift in the machining or what did you
do we got a bunch of new younger people
who are really smart yeah that is that
is by far the the biggest effect and and
because they were yeah like miraculously
they showed up just at the right time
you know in this they they showed up for
graduate school and like 2010 or 2011
right when we happen to need them yeah
you know without without knowing about
the timing they just showed up yeah and
they finished some classes and then they
decided to ship out and live at these
remote
Louisiana sights in Louisiana and
Washington yeah and they they just
figured it all out
they just day in and day out they just
figured out every problem and solved it
and so what yeah what like what are some
concrete examples I mean there were some
engineering changes and going into this
this new detector which was 10 times
more powerful laser and we isolated the
mirrors a lot better from the
environment and the mirrors are much
higher quality either super beautiful
and much heavier and really good so
there's a bunch of these technical
things which were changed yeah but and
each one of them on their own worked
really well because the engineers who
were constructing them did a great job
that the problem was when trying to put
it all together and you know these
things just never reveal themselves when
you're sitting in a little room and
designing your widget but you put it in
a suitcase and carried on the airplane
and try to bolt it on to the four
kilometer a billion dollar machine and
then it's just like total disaster
because well yeah when I first heard you
talk you were talking about you know
like deer getting close to the yeah the
tube and all these things and how do you
isolate these things just don't matter
at all here in our labs at Cal Tech
you've measured one thing or two things
but the full problem of putting it all
together and what's the problem that
only shows up when you have you know
hundreds of kilowatts of laser power and
giant mirrors and it's all running
together for example I would say and
then still one of the toughest problems
that and it's not completely solved is
it has to do with the interaction
between the laser beam in the mirrors
and normally when you think about these
things you say well the laser beam goes
out there and it bounces off that thing
and it comes back and that's all there
is to it and maybe the mirror is shaking
around so that's a problem but in fact
there's so much laser power that when
you it's weird to think about but
there's so much laser power when we hit
the mirror it moves the mirror yeah and
the mirror if you imagine it is about
this big mm-hm and it is 40 kilograms
which is like a hundred pounds
80-something but yeah some number of
pounds who knows what pounds mean it's
40 kilograms which is heavy it's like a
little person and in the previous Lego
20 years ago I would just pick up a
mirror and you could carry it in and put
it in but there's no longer any of this
like yeah I'll pick this thing up and
carry the wrong it over in your truck
yeah is way too expensive and way too
heavy but the super heavy thing we're
hanging up hanging from handmade glass
fibers which are super thin and it's
sitting there and swaying around and
when the laser power hits it it just
moves and even more annoyingly when the
mirror moves a little bit like this
the laser beam at the other end four
kilometers away yeah it moves and so
then that mirror twists a little bit
like this and now the reflected beam
moves a little bit and these two things
are talking to each other through this
the pressure from the radiation
the laser light right and that's super
annoying and it doesn't it's not a thing
that you can test if you're in a
tabletop you have to put the whole thing
together you can simulate it and
calculate it as we did right when you
put it together it's a lot more trouble
than expected and that took a long time
to solve it's still not solved yeah it
kind of works but when we start
increasing the laser power a lot of
these interactions happen which are
really troublesome and luckily we have a
fresh stream of new people coming into
grad school yeah and if they we we hope
they they they remain as as good as the
people we've had so far if that doesn't
work out we're in trouble yeah so what
do you suspect will be the changes that
that suspend the mirrors in a way that
the laser doesn't move them oh they're
just going to I don't think we have any
way of doing it what we're doing right
now we have a just a sophisticated
feedback control system that we measure
the light beams which leak out of the
system at a bunch of places we detect it
and then we we have a
a system of something like 20 feedback
loops which which puts forces on the
mirrors to try to keep it aligned and
keep this from being such a problem
mm-hmm the trouble is well we you know
we're trying to detect gravitational
waves which are tiny and so when you do
something you imagine like this let's
imagine like this is the the mirror and
this little met this little ting which
is which is about how long the
gravitational wave lasts like this and
now now we're trying to control the
pointing of this thing because it's
getting steered on by the beam and so I
have my can feedback control like this
trying to hold it on but you can't do
this if you're just if there is the
whole thing yeah it just screws up the
whole thing if you're applying too much
feedback because you mask the signal
that you're trying to detect right and
so we're in we're in a place where we
would like to figure out how to better
optimize our feedback controls so that
they don't mask the gravitational wave
signal so much and luckily there is a
community which thinks about how to
optimize control systems and they've
been a great help to us but we're now at
the limit we're at the limit of what I
understand and so I'm looking for
someone who knows more than me to help
us improve this situation better
and I hope some of our modern learning
techniques and signal processing
techniques can be used yeah for this
well yeah I mean I want to talk to you
about that as well like how are you what
techniques are you're playing right now
to the data and what do you hope to
apply in the future you know there's a
whole menu of things we basically
everything that we can find we just read
a lot of things on the internet and
everything that sounds clever we want to
use it so since 10 years ago or more we
have been trying every single kind of
linear subtraction so we have I don't
know let's say tens of thousands of sin
which are measuring the environment and
the move and the motion and these
feedback controls and all kinds of
things like this and we take each one of
those and we compute the optimal Wiener
filter which is the yeah it's the
optimal filter that you can apply to the
sensor signal and subtract it from the
data and so we use it in some cases we
calculate the filter and then directly
drive the mirrors so that in hardware we
remove the noise before it's actually
made hmm
so we do that with a lot of things and
so we remove you know by about a factor
of a hundred some large noise horses
that way in the in the hardware hmm and
we do it in the hardware because they
would they would mix into some sort of
nonlinear way back into the data so it's
better to clean up the data and the
hardware in the analog because there's
sort of no there's no dynamic range
limit and analog there's no number of
bits more or less atoms so there's a lot
of bits once we get into the data
there's still more we can do so we do
some more linear subtraction of noise
and we're able to improve the data a
little bit by factors of a few okay but
now we've reached the limit of what you
can do with linear noise subtraction
mm-hm and we need some better ideas on
how to do the next thing and the next
thing involves nonlinear regression so
one of the things I'm working on right
now is how to take basically a huge data
set
depends who you're talking to when you
say huge data set it doesn't really huge
data set for me but not a huge data set
for a lot of other people I guess we
have thousands of signals which are
recorded at which are 16-bit and
recorded at 16 kilohertz and some of
these signals not all of them will
combine in some sort of via some sort of
nonlinear function and show up in our
main data stream where we look like to
look for the gravitational waves
for example it might be like the cosine
of one signal times another signal plus
another signal and then that whole thing
squared or cubed or something like that
so it's not super strange so it's it's
the kind of thing you can imagine doing
on a laptop mm-hmm but it's a little
tough to search it through the full
space of sensors and so we haven't we
just haven't done it yet mm-hmm
but I think a lot of the the things that
are masking the lowest frequency
gravitation waves which come from the
biggest black holes that data can be
cleaned up quite a lot if we were to
come up with better techniques for doing
it and I'd and I think it's all doable
mm-hmm just I personally haven't found
the algorithm to do it but we're working
on it because there have been three now
in the past handful of years right right
there was one in September 15th of 2015
and then there was one on Christmas Day
of that year in the evening around 9
o'clock and then for almost a year we
shut down to improve a lot of things in
a detector from most of 2016 basically
okay and then we turned back on November
December of last year and then we had
another detection in January but do you
suspect there have been many more that
you just can't yeah yeah yeah you know I
think in our data
there must be probably we could double
the number of signals we have right now
if we were to and that's my that's my
guess it could be much more okay and and
the reason is you know this imagine if
you imagine this is my only prop so I'm
going to use this is this works for
everything so if you imagine this is
this lip is a black hole here when I do
this if I can hold it right yeah let me
hold this part all right this is not
cooperating yeah there you it rings a
little bit and that
ringing frequency has to do with
something complicated about the
vibrations of this thing in the water
that's in it the black hole however is a
really really simple animal the
mathematics are really complicated or
depends who you ask pretty company yes
yeah yes yeah I would say it's really
simple it's more challenging this is
this is about as challenging as the
mathematics for the black hole the
physics are stranger but complicated
things are complicated
anyway the black hole that's just
sitting there not spinning you can
easily compute the frequency at which it
rings mm-hm and it has to do with the
amount of time it takes light to travel
around the the border so once you know
the size of the black hole if you're
looking at it or if you know its mass
you can compute the frequency at which
its gonna ring so it's sitting here and
let's imagine I throw like this class
into the black hole as this class gets
really close to it the black hole
horizon will be perturbed a little bit
like this as it swallows this new piece
of mass and then that perturbation
immediately settles down and there's a
little wave that travels around the edge
of the black hole and then that gets
radiated out mmm that radiation is what
we detect mm-hmm so when the two big
black holes merge together the same
thing happens they form a bigger black
hole but now since the things bigger the
frequency of the ringing will be bigger
just like if I made this cup two times
bigger this frequency would be two times
lower so the bigger something is the
free the resonant frequency is lower
okay so the biggest black holes we can't
find right now because this kind of
technical noise feedback and the
vibrations from the environment are
bigger than the fundamental quantum
physics limits of measurement and that
all of that data is being measured by
other sensors microphones and things
like that so it's a it's a data it's a
data science job right now and figure
out how to take thousands of standard
sensors you can buy off-the-shelf yeah
and mix that data somehow with the
gravitational wave data stream in a
smart way that removes this kind of
foreground
allows you to find the deeper signals
but it's all modeled because that's what
I was wondering unmodeled yeah because
when I saw the first announcement of the
two black holes
I was wondering like oh did they just
have they just been looking for this
pattern of waves or what this pattern
the whole time and so that you kind of
have like a guidebook like okay let me
see this it means that there's a bunch
of different variables which
characterize the black holes I yeah I
made it sounds simple but they can be
spinning and depending on their orbits
and that sort of thing there's a lot of
parameters that maybe several parameters
that go into it
okay but in the end it's just some
parameter so we might have a 5 or 10
dimensional waveform space that we
search through but it is a just a big
catalog of waveforms little little
wavelet looking things and so for all
the signals that can possibly come from
black holes yeah we think we can we can
search for them just by comparison
comparing with a known template really
and so that's just the the wavelength
and the amplitude that was well the
frequency evolves as the signal comes in
so when they're far away you know when
they first born maybe they're a million
years before merging and so they're far
apart and they just spin together like
this and as they get closer eventually
there's a little woo and then they pop
together so we but we know what that
frequency evolution is based on their
masses and how they start and so then do
you think in addition to you know paying
more attention to all the other
measurements that you're doing there's
going to be a hardware innovation like
what what happens next
yeah I think you know hopefully someone
will watch this podcast and then say
have I got the solution for you and I'll
just get a piece of someone send me a
link to their github and then that will
have the whole answer
yeah and then we'll break this thing
wide open this year or next year yeah
and then and then we'll be back more at
the fundamental limits so you asked
before about this mirror new mirrors
yeah sort of thing and again you
the universal prop here so with this if
I do it so that rings for about a second
and that has a frequency of 500 Hertz
and so that means the the energy stays
pretty well localized in the vibration
of the glass and doesn't go someplace
else and this is I don't even think mine
is something I found in this hallway
right but it's an okay piece of glass
but it's not meant for any animation
it's not meant for scientific purposes
and the mirrors we have are more like
they store the energy better something
like about 10,000 times longer so if I
were to ping one of those those would
last for you know hours they would just
keep ringing and ringing and that has to
do with that tells you a little bit
about how well you can measure the
motion of that mirror using lasers and
the reason for it is because of the
motion of the atoms and the thermal
energy in the system when you come down
to it if you've removed every other
noise from the outside world you just
have a thing sitting there mm-hmm
because it's sitting at a finite
temperature its molecules are bouncing
around like this and it's shaking and
that there's that's just sort of a
thermodynamic limit that you can can't
get past mm-hmm but the question is is
there a pattern to the way that they're
moving or are they just moving randomly
mm-hmm and if you have something like
this dumpy old glass it's pretty much
moving randomly except for there will be
a lot of energy in the different
harmonics and tones that you can make so
if you measured this thing you would
notice that there would be a lot of
oscillations that had a certain
frequency so is that how you can you can
measure something actually rather the
laser is also affected by the
gravitational wave it is yeah right so
is the the resonance of the mirror so
that's the reason why you can measure it
because you can shoot it after and it's
still resonating and you pick it up
no no it's it's just that we just look
we just ignore the frequencies at which
the mirror resonates mirror resonates at
a few specific tones like you can think
about it like waves on a string if you
have a guitar or violin depending upon
how you Fred it I don't understand
violence anyway
instruments with frets I understand here
so depending on where you fret a guitar
string it plays a different tone and it
just has to do with the length of the
wire and the tension and the same for
the mirror the mirror depends on a
something like how heavy it is and how
how fast sound travels in the mirror and
so if you have a mirror that's really
really pure then all of that
thermodynamic energy is focused in just
a few frequencies and so it's just
sitting there and if you and if you
shoot it with a laser with a very
expensive system you can hear the
thermodynamic vibrations of the
molecules in there and in fact that's
what we hear most of the time mm-hmm and
so if you listen to the LIGO data stream
there are these high frequency ringing
going on all the time and it's all the
mirrors just constantly vibrating
thermally and so okay so we just don't
we just don't look for gravitational
waves at those very specific frequencies
but they're very narrow so it's just
like doing the removal of like the
powerline harmonics yeah we have all of
that so we have to remove it so if you
have a hum filter as you do when you
record music for example you do the same
thing so we have hum filters that remove
right all the lines that are happening
well it's kind of like why you're
measuring everything right because
you're just like if you can detect it
then you take it out that's therefore
not a gravitational wave yeah and so do
you suspect that you're picking up
picking up anything that you you can't
even define right now like are you
lumping things in as gravitational waves
that might not even be I don't think
that's unlikely that's unlikely that's I
mean it's always a worry yeah we're
really paranoid about that kind of thing
because you just hate to be like the boy
who cried wolf say
I have gravitational-wave and then you
find out six months later that it's it's
just a misbehaving refrigerator that was
located we bought the same fridge and in
in Washington I'm sure we did I'm sure
there's something going on like that and
so those problems we've been finding for
four decades things like we bought the
same electronics board from the same
manufacturer and it has a crystal that
happens to radiate at a certain
frequency and those two things are kind
of synchronous at two different places
and once in a while you'll get like
three crystals beating with each other
which will produce something in the
audiogram and there's there's thousands
of stories like that which we all forget
because you do it you find it and then
you take the thing out and you smash it
with a hammer yeah you have a party
because you found some terrible thing do
you have like a wiki of known bugs
yeah chronicling all this stuff no yeah
I think it's just stories okay it's
mostly stories cuz that's like most of
the job it sounds like yeah it is it is
you just like find anything get rid of
it all the time all the time that is all
and it and it's just it's gotten to the
point where we all feel like we're
telling UFO stories because we've
already found all the easy things years
ago and now the things that are limiting
us are the weirdest mechanisms and you
come back you spend a day you know
working late it's like 2:00 a.m. and
then everybody kind of comes back
together and like what what happened
what you find and then you start telling
this crazy story you say it seems like
if I stand in this part of the room and
then she stands over there and then we
turned the mirror like this this kind of
hooting screeching noise happens and
everyone's like you're crazy
there's no science in that it sounds
like a superstition yeah I don't know
what to tell you it's 2:00 a.m. we've
been working on this all day but this is
what happens and I'm sorry let's let's
go get some sleep and think think about
this and all the problems are of that
sort now okay but luckily we have people
who are obsessed about these kinds of
problems and there
going at it and finding them in solving
them and this summer or last summer we
found another one of these problems as
like it reminds me of some kind of
sci-fi horror movie trying to think of
what it is it's like there's this really
bad movies from the 80s called they live
I haven't seen it yeah they have two
professional wrestlers I think are the
actors in it anyway that it's terribly
bad but at one point one of the guys
says like you need to put on these
glasses because if you put on these
glasses you can see who the aliens are
they mostly look like people should
ammonia okay and so the guy puts it on
and then he started looking around it's
like all of his friends and everybody he
knows it's just like he doesn't want to
know it's too much
and we found a problem like that last
year which is that the light which which
bounces off of our mirrors mostly keeps
going back and forth and these optical
resonators that we have that's something
like a few parts per million of the
light shoots off in some other direction
mm-hmm and then it shoots off hits some
unknown thing and then some few parts
per million comes back and then
interferes with the main system and so
then it's something like there's
basically an infinity yeah it's like a
disco ball you can imagine like a disco
ball is lit and then the light beans go
everywhere that's an extreme case but at
the part per million level our mirrors
as wonderful as they are acting like
disco balls and so a little bits of
light are heading off in all directions
and when the light comes back from those
places it has picked up a little of the
vibration from whatever thing it hit and
so finally at some level a bit we're
measuring the acoustical vibrations of
the entire eight kilometers of metal
tubing of our system
because there's a little bit of light
hitting those things and coming back and
then you know No
yeah I mean that's kind of like the rub
of you create these like perfect sealed
systems but now it's sealed yeah and so
you just throw marble around and just
going yeah he just keeps coming and
hello yeah we've got to take care of it
so we've been here at Caltech and also
at MIT we've been thinking about what to
do about this and so we've come up with
some designs I'm what to do and
basically we've taken some of these
substances which are the you know like
the blackest darkest things you've ever
seen and we're going to put them in our
system to block in places where the
light beam goes so how do you open it
yeah we're going to open up the vacuum
system and walk inside we're gonna put
on full cleanroom suits and then walk
inside and put these things in wearing
it all over every place that we can find
I never want to see this again ooh what
kind of substance is it and I don't
probably understand like my shirt before
washing was very black yeah now it's
kind of gray yeah but what you mean are
you asking why are things black no and
it's a good question you can answer that
yeah it's like spinal tap it's a real
it's a really it's an honest scientific
question is it like a paint that you're
putting on stuff that's what I'm asking
it's all yeah it's a bunch of different
so each these are the kinds of trivia
questions that I know and then I wonder
why you know what have I done with my
life that I know the answer to these
things in the in the array of different
blackening things there are the things
that you think are black which are black
sort of to your eye but then you shoot a
huge laser at it and you use a really
sensitive detector to sense it and then
you find out it's not so black it's
really gray and so there's a bunch of
garbage you can buy online which says
that it's the best blah blah blah blah
blah most of its junk so we have a
couple of engineers in a building over
here who have been exhaustively and
carefully looking at every single thing
that that is
promised to be black on the internet and
then you know it's like a Mythbusters
episode over there yeah and there and
then finally you have come down to a few
different solutions and so some of them
are I don't think I could accurately
describe all of them but some of them
are black like it's basically glass like
this but like colored glass like missing
the word for it and to have it in
churches what do you call a stained
glass stained glass yeah so you have
glass and then when you're making the
glass you put some other stuff in it and
it comes out a different color right and
so you can make you can I don't know
what I'm doing I'm here they don't but
I've I don't know make glass so I don't
understand but I imagine it's like this
you have this molten glass and then you
pick up like food coloring magic pixie
dust yeah and you put in some stuff and
it's perfectly absorptive for the
wavelength of the laser you're looking
at you care about so yeah sure red
stained glass for instance let's through
red light but it absorbs green so red
stained glass is really good if you have
a green laser mm-hmm we have an infrared
laser which is if you imagine this is
the whole rainbow from purple violet
anyway violet to red then our laser is
sort of over here so it's yeah anyway
imagine the rainbow and there it is it
has a wavelength of 1 micron mm-hm and
so for it some of the things that look
black don't work but if you have a
special kind of welders glass it really
works
welders glass as good as good at
absorbing pretty much everything with a
longer wavelength and green mm-hmm so
that's one of the best materials to use
for blackening and then you can also get
these so called nanotubes things like
vented vantablack I don't remember all
the various black names but they're all
trademarked okay there's a bunch of
stuff which is essentially you know you
can get lost in a forest it's like that
for light beams also so if you take a
thing and you put a bunch of spaghetti
looking nanotubes things then the light
goes in and bounces around like a
hundred million times and so loses all
of its energy
- okay and so then do you do you also
expect like you're going to build more
more infirmities that are longer yeah um
to clean it up
Oh to clean it up or in general like do
you suspect that like that the next
version is a kilometer I don't really
know but okay um
it is a good question it's actually
that's a really interesting question
about if longer we'll clean it up I have
to get back to you on that but that's
probably a few days of computing for me
yeah indeed if we make the
interferometers longer like ten times
longer yeah now that's dramatically good
I mean it will cost a lot of money
mm-hmm but that would take us from being
able to measure things which are sort of
I would say with the current systems you
know as big as they are if we put in
like our best technical hacks into them
that we can imagine we could maybe get
to the place where the universe was
about of mmm
one fifth or one sixth of its current
age mm-hmm so we could look back
something like 10 billion years into the
past which is pretty great but if we
build systems which were 10 times bigger
it's hard to it's hard to do anything
better than just make this system bigger
the bigger you make it the bigger the
signal gets and a lot of people have
thought about the idea of making a 40
kilometer system which you can put there
are several places in the US for example
which have each arm is 40 K yeah so big
open spaces which are unused and if we
could find a place like that and get the
funding to build something like that it
would be traumatic traumatic
I hope not dramatic dramatic sound if
the laser gets out yeah yeah it would be
dramatic and be wonderful we would be
able to find signals from basically the
all the way back I mean
would really yeah we would we would find
the first stars in the universe and if
any we're collapsing if they exist which
I think they do but it would be so
dramatic we'd be able to measure things
like how did space-time evolve from
those early times and did the universe
start from different number of spatial
dimensions and sort of unpack as it
expanded and become three-dimensional
did it start different and did did it go
through a phase were it like an extra
dimension came up and then collapsed
again and who knows we'd also like to
know does gravity travel through the
three dimensional space or is it
something like there's another spatial
dimension which only gravity can see and
so it's something from that far back
into the universe may have I don't know
how to draw this I don't think this
thing cup can't do it the cup water out
of a cup can do it I can do it watch
watch this so imagine that we're living
on the surface of this cup sure and this
is effectively like our
three-dimensional universe and sure now
if I empty the cup then when I go like
this the signal has to travel around the
border of the cup but because there's
water inside when I go down here some of
the vibration gets into the water and
comes out this other side and so there's
sort of this boundary on which we're
used to everything taking place which is
the three dimensions that we're familiar
with but there could be a fourth
dimension which is something like this
bulk the inner part hmm and in that
dimension gravity could travel faster so
it'll look like it's going faster than
the speed of light but that kind of
stuffs is kind of blowing my mind yeah
I'm trying to fix ounds like yeah it
sounds like there's just a crazy person
who you found on the streets and is just
telling you stuff about other dimensions
I think about it man
ten billion years ago man ten billion
years ago there's other dimensions and
they're half dimensions and maybe we
unfolded from a flower it's all on the
table I'll tell you in the late 90s when
I was starting grad school
everything felt like it was pretty much
wrapped up mmm the word on the street
was like well thanks for showing up but
we've got this all wrapped up now and
everything makes sense in the universe
is exactly like we predicted it we have
a few loose ends to tie up and this is
the the same thing that people were
saying in the late 1890s also they said
we got it all we figured it out we got
magnets
we've got electric fields kept telescope
that's all there is there's nothing else
out there and then there was this weird
quantum thing that people they there was
some data but they were like that's not
real that's just some nonsense it's
gonna go away and we're back into that
period now where everything's back on
the table the universe is so strange and
so far inexplicable that if you have got
an idea that's a crazy idea then your
crazy idea is just as good as my crazy
idea yeah and let's put it to a test if
it's a if it's a hypothesis which is
testable we ought to test it so then
does it make sense to build an infirmary
or in space like people have been
talking about yeah of course I know it
sounds cool yeah that's a plus yeah
that's a plus that it sounds cool um it
makes sense for a lot of reasons I would
say on the ground kind of we're limited
to measure things that are that have a
signal frequency which is more than five
or ten Hertz or something like that so
we can go a little bit below the human
audio band I credit not much and the
reason for that is that the earth is
just vibrating all the time mmm and you
talked about these animals before the
animals are gonna be a problem that the
clouds are a problem I mean eventually
the gravity from the clouds and the
gravity from beavers and hummingbirds
and whatever I mean who knows what else
out there but you can omit Washington
State there's not a lot of animals out
there but there's tumbleweed and those
things are fierce if you have never been
chased by a tumbleweed mini tornado
and then you're lucky and in Louisiana
there's a lot of animals and yeah okay
you could build bigger buildings but
eventually the gravity from the
gravitational fluctuations from the from
the dirt and from the air clouds I mean
eventually you it's just too much
gravity fluctuation on the earth we just
can't get past it so we can remove every
other kind of noise but we can't go
putting vibration sensors and all the
clouds or something like that that's
kind of not yet we're getting to the
Baron Munchausen kind of crazy level so
we could go to the moon but the moon's
not all that quiet and the near Earth
orbit is not also not really that good
okay for vibrations and it's it's not a
place you want to put a stable system so
to have a space interferometer it's got
to be on a fry-up far-out kind of orbit
that you can get to with things like
SpaceX Falcon Heavy and so there's a
project called Lisa which is aimed to
launch in 16 years 16 17 years from now
and that will put a system a triangular
interferometer in space which is several
interferometers and that will measure
gravitational waves at around at milla
hertz so super low frequency but those
you know at that at that level there's
almost no vibration out there and they
should be able to measure things all
over the universe in super super hi-fi
so we're measuring things with a
signal-to-noise ratio of tens and we and
we hope to get to signal-to-noise ratios
of thousands which is really good but
they would be hundreds of times better
than that and it would be like it's one
of the if you're a real depends if
you're a real connoisseur of violin or
cello or some of these things different
different musicians have a different
finger signature a little bit so when
they're playing you can you can hear
things like the way that their their
finger moves on the bow or the way
their finger moves on the string you've
like a little bit of the friction mmm
you can hear these little like it's tiny
wide yeah yeah a little bit of the slide
but you hear these little things which
change the character of the music and I
know if if you leave one of these
instruments sitting for too long the
sound you know I like some of these
instruments like to be played they warm
up a little bit the wood warms up and
then becomes more like a warm instrument
and if you if you listen to it on I
don't know like it 80's cassette deck
with a Walkman you're never gonna hear
that stuff you need to have a full -
Amanda and then you then you really you
feel it you hear it you know you need
the these are kind of the things in the
live performance that you'll never get
otherwise mmm I've been to the Berlin
Philharmonic and that is that's what I'm
talking about
if you want to understand about why we
need better gravitational wave detectors
you go and you sit there and like row
five or ten yeah and these are some of
the best musicians in the world and
they'll play pieces that you know but
you've never heard like that until
you're and there's no recording that's
ever gonna do it because you've you feel
you feel it in your chest and you feel
it all over your body the sound and it's
a kind of richness that there's no way
to record mm-hmm and that's the kind of
feeling that we want to get from what's
happening out in space and for that we
needed exquisite hi-fi system to get
these little things and it's not just
for the pleasure of oh look that black
hole did exactly what we predicted it's
more for we'd like to find out where the
laws of physics break down and where
something new pops up if we want to find
out other extra dimensions and new kinds
of particles and is space and time
really just a illusion and then there's
really microscopic graininess - empty
space and that's that's kind of the
underlying question cuz I like I mean
you'd said so many reasons before but I
wonder what the pitch was in the
beginning like why why do this and like
obviously it's you know quest for
knowledge it's great you know but like
is where those the concrete answers that
people gave like why are you doing this
why make it bigger what do you do yeah I
think for everybody there's a different
reason for it there's a whole spectrum
of reasons
so I'm just I always tell people the
thing that I'm most interested in which
is I think gravity we've never been able
to use it as a real probe of what's
going on in the universe what's the
universe made out of what is all this
stuff
why is space empty why spaced it's so
stiff and why are there quantum
fluctuations in empty space and how come
the universe ended up looking the way it
does why the galaxies so far apart and
how come there are galaxies why don't
they just have a bunch of planets or
just floating around yeah why planet how
come planets are smaller than so I mean
just it's like an endless number of
questions about the whole not really
this stuff in our universe but the the
structure of everything and why did it
end up like this it could have been any
number of things and then we don't even
know what space is made out of
what's empty space it sounds like a
question that's that's stupid and
doesn't have any meaning to it but you
know if you're I don't know you imagine
like two sturgeon floating around in the
water they're like a hundred years old
and they've gotten used to it they don't
really ask anymore what is water but you
you know we know we can take it out and
look at it microscope and it's got the
llege Elam's and all kinds of stuff and
it's made out of h2o which we can study
and it has a real microscopic character
which is important and we need to
understand it and for those fish it
doesn't really matter it just seems like
a continuum it's just everything is that
stuff but there is a whole deep
structure to it and space may be like
that it's just this whole you know it's
like opening the curtain on the real
universe and what's really going on what
is the structure that we're living on it
could just be this weird framework way
that we never imagined and asking
then you can I think totally legitimate
question is so what and let's say you
fight like you we've revealed the true
structure of space-time and it's like a
bunch of leprechauns down there building
space or who knows some crazy thing just
blacks paint and then yeah and then so
what what does that do for me
is that gonna relieve the traffic in LA
yeah yeah no probably not so really
really it's it's a curiosity driven
research we're trying to figure out how
to find out reveal the unknown and
what's going on and these these big
science projects really expensive mmm
and a lot of people are involved and
they work at it and then and then you
really wonder so what they found out
stuff like there's this particle or not
that particle or this started something
1 billion years before you know 6
billion years old and that five billion
or whatever but I I think if that really
was all that there is to it you could
certainly make the legitimate argument
that look our society has got a lot of
problems that we need to solve and then
how much or how much of our resources
are we gonna put into pure curiosity
driven basic research which doesn't have
any kind of finite time line payoff and
we get real things we want to solve here
that people going hungry what are we
gonna do and I would say to that you
look at the history in the last hundred
years and why has you know why has
wealth increased and standards of living
increased all over the world you know
and the reason for it is that people
have been investing a lot in basic
science for for hundreds of years and
the reason that the u.s. became the
leader in this as the government said
soon after World War two that that we
got to be serious and put our money into
this because there is really a huge
payoff and we don't really care what
you're researching just do something you
mean find something that excites you and
do
and do it really well and and if you're
interested in engineering in science and
technology we are going to support that
because we we've shown decade after
decade that it's a huge hugely
profitable payoff investment wise it
pays off and gadgets and learning and
wealth for the country in the long term
and it's never fails so you'll always
have you know you'll always be funding
something which turns out to be a dumb
idea
and then okay so it doesn't work out but
you know to find a really great idea you
might have to test out ninety-nine dumb
ideas and you might not understand why
they're bad until you do it yeah but
relative to the outcome I think it makes
a lot of sense cool I think that's a we
have a couple questions from Twitter so
we can transition into those to get this
one the right Twitter all right Dennis
Thornton asks what would happen to earth
if there is a black hole merger closer
to home than the three detected say
where Sagittarius a star is now mmm-hmm
that's not close enough to really do
anything to us but you could imagine it
being even closer mm-hmm so let's see if
it's too close it just eats the earth
and that's not interesting we're just
dead but there's some range of distances
at which other things could happen so
you could imagine for example it being
out by oh I'd say like at the next star
system like Alpha Centauri or something
like that and so we could we can compute
it like the ones we detected we're at
let's say several hundred million
light-years and Alpha Centauri is only
four light years I believe so it would
be stronger by that factor of a hundred
million and which sounds like a lot it
is a lot but that means that that motion
of 10 to the minus 18 meters it would
have been
10 to the minus 10 meters which for us
would have been like a hardware
destroying level of signal really yeah
we would have just had electronics
overload and saturated and we would have
just ignored it because we was as way to
is from the levels are too much yeah it
can't be right but it would not have
done anything like disrupt the tides or
knocked the moon out of orbit or
anything like that it would have to be
extremely close for something like that
right in so close that we might even
already we would see it with our optical
telescopes no sure for sure for it for
it to hurt us yeah and it also would
have been would have happened already
right yeah well you could imagine I'm
trying to think of all the nightmare
disaster scenarios so let's say let's
say a pair of black holes gets formed in
some weird three-way encounter in a
nearby cluster and then it gets shot out
and it's traveling at like a million
meters per second so it's like a like a
1% the speed of light and it's shooting
at us and it's coming at us from some
strange direction so that we don't see
it because it's occluded by something
else I don't know what that would be I'm
sure something I can't simulate the
whole solar system in my head so I can't
figure out the answer to this but let's
say it's coming from out of the plane
and then eventually we see it it's like
including some stars right and so I'm
thinking of this Hollywood movie that we
would make oh it on this idea so it's
coming to us and and the binary is doing
this as it's traveling and as it's comes
like it's gonna merge right when it hits
the solar system somehow and I don't
know what we would do to stop this yeah
I don't know what there would be but it
could it could I mean we could compute
something like that and then that thing
would really be bad because it would
stretch space by like I was saying like
hundreds of percent right when it got
close to us and the black hole's
themselves would be about the size of LA
and so they would be effectively like
tiny pinpricks but you know might be
like 50 or 100 kilometers in size mm-hmm
and they would be able to
I don't think the earth would get
destroyed however mmm so I can't say
this with high confidence but the earth
again using this hmm
the earth is a physically resonant
system and this thing has a quality
factor of a few thousand meaning it's
like a few thousand oscillations when I
ring it that's why it lasts for a second
so the earth is like that also except
for the vibration frequency is about 30
minutes so 30 times once per 30 seconds
and so if the gravitational if the
binary black hole pair came cruising
through our solar system and right when
it was coming through if it happened to
be going once per 30 seconds
yeah it could excite the acoustic modes
of the earth and that would be bad it
would be it would like be bigger than
the 9.5 earthquake in Chile which
happened in the early 60s and kept the
earth ringing for months I don't know
what would happen exactly but I can
imagine if we had 10 times bigger than
the world's biggest earthquake hurt us
in terms of earthquakes and tsunamis
yeah or we would find out what the
inside of a black hole looks like forgot
to close yeah
all right that's an interesting question
and when I should I should compute all
right I will answer on Twitter
perfect okay so we got one more than
this is from a margin collector is the
current method for detecting gravity
gravitational waves the best idea out
there or only the best practical way Oh
given the tech it is not the best idea
out there so there's an in a number of
ways I mean one way is making things
longer as people said but I what I
gather from this question I'm reading
between the lines here but is there some
like but there's a good at you on musk
story where I think his his analogy is
like you know we take New York City in
the 1800s and that's all horses and then
we ask like what's going to happen to
the output of all the [ __ ]
once New York City scales 20 million hmm
you can't just scale everything by
saying I have like more horses and we'll
have so many more street sweepers or
something eventually you shift to a new
technology like cars and so it's the
same like the normal answer I think
people would give to are we using the
best technology is of no you know next
year we're gonna use double the laser
power and a mirror that's even double
make it longer yeah but like in the
Simpsons they said you know eventually
these humans will make a board with a
nail so big through it that they'll
destroy themselves
so yeah it's not a it's not the right
way to go if you ask in a hundred years
from now will people still build
Mikaelson laser interferometers new the
same thing right I have a hard time
believing that's true right and one of
the exciting possibilities out there so
there are ideas with using acoustic
detectors and space detectors and using
the timing of signals in space and so on
but in this frequency band in the audio
frequency band I think me and and some
of the people who think about the
quantum mechanics of this kind of
detector have been thinking about how
far are we if you think about pure the
pure mathematics of how information is
propagated through space-time like
what's the information carrying
capability in terms of number of bits of
space yeah but this much space and how
many bits can you send before space
collapses on itself and like with fiber
optics you have a limit to the number of
bits you can send which depends on your
modulation bandwidth and the amount of
laser power you can put in the fiber and
eventually if you put too much laser
power and there you get stimulated
beyond scattering from the glass and so
on either kind of a bandwidth limit
there which is which is pretty high it's
plenty for YouTube but it's it's still
there is a limit and and we have been
thinking about the same kind of thing
and why aren't we doing better or
where's all the signal-to-noise ratio
going when you think about the wave
coming from outer space we think
probably the quantum fluctuations of
space-time itself are probably at the
scale which is 10 to the minus 34 meters
and the signal like I said is around 10
to the minus 18 or 19 or something so
there's a signal-to-noise ratio of 10 to
the 14 or 15 there and I'm telling you
we're only getting tens so there's a 10
to the 13 and the signal-to-noise is
lost from converting from space time to
laser light that doesn't seem a good
thing there's got to be that since
that's the biggest chunk of where we're
losing it we should be doing something
better to transduce the space-time
curvature into an electrical signal and
it might be that light is not the best
thing but even with light we can do a
lot better than what we're doing and not
just by making things heavier and
doubling this or switching colors or
something there's a there's an idea
which is around which is called coherent
quantum feedback and that takes this
idea of it takes this problem I would
guess I would say of the pressure from
the light moving the mirrors around and
turning it into an advantage so like I
described before the beam bounce the
beam pushes this thing and then this
thing pushes back and that changes the
light mm-hmm well you can you can take
this instability and essentially turning
it into a system where quantum
mechanically the mirror laser system has
positive feedback a lot like a yeah like
an audio system you've heard like when
musicians practice sometimes or I mean
it can be bad so right when people have
feedback they're standing too close to
the like two mics next to each other
Jennsen yeah but as we know from Jimi
Hendrix feedback can also be a wonderful
thing mm-hmm and he turned it into a
fantastic thing from just an annoyance
so we'd like to do the same thing so
we'd like to take this mechanical
optical instability that comes from the
laser system interacting with itself and
turn the entire four kilometer plus four
kilometer l-shaped thing into a unstable
feedback system so when the space time
fluctuation comes in it excites this
instability you know instability in our
system and then we detect the signals in
a much stronger way
and so rather than think about it like
the laser light goes and measures the
space and comes back it's almost like we
have this eight kilometer l-shaped laser
hmm tuning fork that picks up the
space-time signal right so it's
optimized for that one particular length
and so it just goes it goes wild when
it's easy or something yeah
but in fact I mean you can you can
optimize it for a single frequency but
the thing we've been thinking about just
in the last month or two is how to
optimize make it optimum for a wide band
so we want to make a wideband unstable
system to be determined do it yeah yeah
yeah
I think we have got 95% of the problem
solved oh wow and on paper okay that
still our our aim is to try to build
something like this this year and once
we figure out how to do it and just like
a scale model you mean yeah like you're
on it at oak on the Caltech campus we
have a 40 meter size system oh okay and
it is a it's a 1/100 scale of the real
LIGO detector and we want to build this
in so we have we have little mirrors and
little lasers and they seem big to us
but they're they're really little and
we're gonna build up this instability
and see how sensitive we can become very
cool okay cool
thanks man
you